[Music]
the Yakuza series sits at a unique place
in 2018 juggling two different points in
the series timeline the Western release
of prequel Yakuza 0 in 2017 was a
dazzling gateway for a new wave of
players and flowed naturally into a
remake of the very first game later that
year the next tunnel that followed
whoever was Yakuza 6 which bid farewell
to mainstay protagonist Kazuma Kiryu
while debuting the brand-new Dragon game
engine yeah cuz the 6 was a great finale
to a saga that began in 2006 but now the
series has taken another ten-year leap
backward in terms of its narrative
chronology but has taken its latest
technology with it and it's fortunate
that things worked out this way because
yeah Kazakh ami 2 combines the best
parts of both
timelines as we simultaneously revisit
the point in time where the series hit
its stride while being able to enjoy the
superior benefits of a seamless world
and fluid combat system afforded by the
latest engine
[Music]
now the original Yakuza 2 is more than
just a personal favorite
it's where the series became more
ambitious in terms of its world and
narrative by introducing a new location
for the first time your second strip of
Dantan brewery in addition to camera cha
in Tokyo this not only added variety and
scope to each geography and narrative
that memorable personalities with the
Saucon characters their demeanor
contrasts greatly to the Tokyo natives
and this plays into the tensions between
major crime organisations in the Kansai
and Kanto regions respectively fury
teams up with a Sasaki detective Caruso
Yama for the majority of the game who is
a strong likeable character their odd
couple' pairing and growing relationship
as some of the things that make yeah cos
are two so exceptional supporting them
on the familiar darte and his hearted
and former mentor Kawara who all played
interesting roles with great
performances it's here where you can see
the strong foundation for the multi
protagonists approach that this series
would later take and in general kwame to
script is tweaked slightly to be a
little more self reflective from the
lens of a present-day retrospective in
typical series fashion the majority of
the story is taught through highly
charged emotional cutscenes that lean
heavily on the beats of Japanese drama
and they are as slow paced as they are
impressive to look at
however Yakuza twos plot has the benefit
of being one of the more exciting and
memorable of this series there's an
unforgettably gruff and showy
antagonists in Ryoji goda a number of
intriguing twists as a multinational
blood feud is uncovered some heavy set
themes about the value of loyalty and
being shaped by a past as well as some
of the series's absurdly excellent
moments like punching a tiger in the
face
[Music]
it's truly wonderful to see this
PlayStation 2 era experience elevated to
modern standards because sharp
cinematics in high fidelity models
really amplify the familiar performances
through subtle facial expressions and
body language but unsurprisingly
character models featured in secondary
cutscenes and the game's numerous sub
story side quests exhibit a perceptible
drop in quality that took away meters
credit the baseline fidelity of
secondary models has notably improved
the honors jarring ly awful as they were
in Yakuza 6 but cooiiy to Sally doesn't
feature full voice acting in all of its
scenarios like 6 dead there are a few
nice exceptions to these rules however
as some of the game's most infamous sub
stories get full cinematic treatment
camera Joe remains a fantastically
atmospheric environment full of
pedestrians and neon lights and exuding
a strong sense of true to life identity
the dragon engine continues to allow for
seamless transitions between the street
stores and combat encounters it's also
nice to revisit a more complete classic
version of the area after only seeing an
abridged version in yuccas a 6-1 teen
bori does suffer some minor cuts from
the original version of Yakuza 2 and a
smaller third area
shin Se Cho is cut altogether but while
these emissions are disappointing from
an enthusiast perspective it doesn't
attract enough from the overall
experience to be a significant stay and
certainly not for new players the 5
category experience system for character
progression returns and so does the
emphasis on eating and drinking for
experience points which continues to be
a positive change for the series that
helps encourage a grounded connection
and familiarity to the urban environment
to roam through now the Dragon engines
version of yuccas is crunchy combat also
continues to be incredibly satisfying
while relatively straight board in terms
of its moveset especially when compared
to the multiple disciplines featuring
Yakuza 0 and Yakuza kwame 1 the momentum
and fluidity of techniques combined with
the emphasis on collateral physics space
damage makes fights exciting and it's
difficult to return to the
characteristically stiff combat of 0 and
Kewanee once you've spent time with it
small but noteworthy classic mechanics
have been reintroduced including charge
moves which you can now buffer a
returning focus on weapons which you can
collect store buy repair and equip as
well as a number of location-based heat
moves where befriended neighborhood
denizens help you humorously and
viciously assault bad guys
in addition to this series of sub
stories Kwame T also has some welcome
minigame activities that gave you ample
opportunity to play with of this tell
combat system in a variety of different
scenarios the best of these are the
underground Coliseum which returns from
the original and pit secure you in a
series of one-on-one cage matches with
fighters from an entertainingly diverse
background of flying disciplines and the
new bounce emissions which throw you
into gauntlets of increasing difficulty
over stocked with weapons environmental
objects and dozens of enemies which make
for some exciting group roles on the
other hand some of Kewanee 2 story
missions have whole liver mechanics from
the original that never really gelled
well to begin with and feel even more
outdated as part of this modernization
there are movable brutes that's soaked
damaged and pound you with couches and
enemies with automatic rifles that you
need to block with a medieval she loved
all things things like these feel like
I'm creative and unnecessary additions
kalam ET also features two new
impressively substantial mini games
featuring real-life Japanese
personalities one is the Cabaret Club
Grand Prix a refined version of the
hostess club management concept seen in
Yakuza 0 and the other is a much
improved version of the underwhelming
Clank raid a strategy minigame from
Yakuza 6 now with a tower defense twist
both of these minigame iterations have
been altered to have a bigger focus on
fast-paced real time micromanagement and
quick decision-making which makes them
more involved and much more exciting as
attractions to potentially invest in
[Music]
as was the case in Yokosuka wha me
fan-favorite character goro majima is
tightly woven into this remake as it
progressed to the main story you'll
gradually unlock the three chapters of
Mudge in my saga an entirely separate
mini campaign which explores how majima
comes to arrive at the position and
disposition that you find him in during
the events of tear you and say Yama's
story while you're able to freely roam
camera Roadshow and so on same bori with
margin model there are some major
differences Maj Amer has no character
progression of its own and cannot earn
XP
there are no substances are
predetermined as large group battles at
certain roadblocks in the map as well as
one on one Street bus panels which we'll
also find in queue to use campaign
without long-term purpose or flexibility
madam is flamboyant knife fighting star
which dazzles initially with a couple of
entertaining heat moves becomes stale
fast his acrobatic moves don't have the
same satisfying impact as curious and it
really feels like you're in complete
control and while that may suit is
character perfectly without the ability
to pick up items or throw enemies it's
difficult to keep things interesting for
yourself here
without his own progression tree few
heat moves and a small set of techniques
modular actually suffers from the loss
of yucca series multiple fighting styles
in a way that cure you does not the
money you earn from defeating enemies in
this mode can be transferred to cure you
in the form of valuable items and
modular has its own unique karaoke song
worth saying but the interactive part of
his mini campaign feel like an
unnecessary grind to see story
cinematics which other places he really
gets the shine and the only good reason
was swapping to margin my saga in the
first place overall it's a missed
opportunity
karoku Dharan which are going it's young
Megumi here
Rema theater Tanaka beetle Takuya
mong-koo narrow the tail of Tokyo and
Osaka cure you and Santa's partnership
in cure you and goddess rivalry remains
one of yukos's best stories in
kilometers minor missteps don't affect
the heart of that experience the
modernization of its presentation and
its mechanics elevated making it
absolutely worth revisiting or
experiencing for the first time
Yakuza is an exemplary if flawed series
that does an incredible job of steeping
you in contemporary Japanese style crime
drama and establishing an evocative
sense of place and Yakuza comics who is
an excellent example of this series at
its best
coupling its most memorable stories and
characters with its most sophisticated
mechanics yet
[Applause]
shrim